[Music]
okay hello everyone my name's
mike smith i'm from pfizer in the uk
and today i'd like to talk to you a
little bit about becoming an rstudio
certified trainer
and this isn't advancing for some reason
there you go so what does our studio
certification training
mean well it means that you can
understand and also demonstrate that you
can apply
modern teaching methods and that you're
a subject matter expert for the topic
that you're becoming certified in
now in the rest of this talk i'd like to
draw an analogy between
learning r and teaching are and training
for
and running a marathon so the first
hundred yards
is awesome you're full of energy you've
got a goal in mind
you know you're gonna achieve it and
it's fantastic the last hundred yards
is also amazing because you're near the
finish line you know you're gonna get a
medal
right it's the 16 weeks and 26 miles in
the middle that's the hard bit
now i have completed four marathons okay
i wouldn't recommend that anyone in this
room come and ask me
how they complete a marathon in a
specific time
i am not a coach for running
but i am a coach for tidy verse so if
you want to learn about tidy verse come
and see me
but i believe that a lot of time when we
look to find people who can do training
for us
we go to people who've used our a lot
you know we'll ask
them but i would think that there's
actually a lot more to teaching people
are
than simply getting someone who knows
how to do it to tell you how
they do it okay so
i would say certification training has
changed how i approach training quite a
lot
and i want to give you some examples
when you're running when you go out the
door
you better have a plan and a root in
mind
right you need to know how far you're
going roughly how long it should take
what your route is so that your three
mile run doesn't
suddenly turn into a six mile run
because you took a wrong turning
there is an analogy there perfectly for
training
this is a concept map as a learner
you want to see what are the concepts in
this lesson how are they related
as a trainer you want to know same same
stuff
what am i training on in this session
how are things related
do i have a through map and also is
there too many things here that i'm
trying to train
in this one session in a marathon
training program
you're gonna build up incrementally bit
by bit
little bit by little bit you don't go
from a one mile run to a 12 mile run
why would you do the same in training
and teaching people are
build it up incrementally also it's
really important to leave gaps
so that your learners can assimilate
what you're teaching
take it on board figure out what how it
works for them
and get ready for the for the next block
of training
and also it's really important to have
little check-ins
have this kind of assessment that says
do you know what
let's just stop let's check that i
understand what you've
done so far and then kind of check out
where what bits i understand what bits i
don't understand
everybody that comes to your training
comes with
you know where they're who they are what
they know already
what they want to get from the training
what they think you're going to train
them on
and what eventually they want to get
from it okay
now on the our studio education github
you'll see some exemplars of these
learner personas i encourage you to go
and have a look these are three of the
ones that are there
and the ideas that they show you you
know give examples of the kinds of
people that might come to your training
i encourage everyone if you're if you're
trying to set up training
think of the people who are coming what
their goals are
and then try to address their goals
now the first time you run a mile it's a
big deal
you may have started on the couch and
the first time you can run that mile
without stopping it's a big deal and it
should be celebrated
almo i would guess that everyone in this
room
has completely forgotten what it's like
to turn our own for the first time
right help these folks out by the time
you can run
six miles a three mile session is easy
right
so things that we might feel are you
know
just a given it's trivial it's easy as
as long-term our users it might be
indistinguishable
from magic for your average beginner
so the ideal in this journey is that you
get your learners from that first
hundred yards where they're feeling
hey i'm gonna learn something new this
is gonna be awesome to the
end where they're crossing the finish
line and getting their medal and help
them
do that and achieve their goals not what
you want them to
to learn and to do that as quickly as
possible
thanks very much